what's up everybody especially those of
you outside of the United States of
America I see a lot of memes being
posted by you oh look at all the UFO
sightings in the last hundred years
they're all in America
why would they go to you do you think
aliens are going to travel light years
away to see a windmill they want to try
air conditioning in the summer Europeans
don't know if they want to try a
Coca-Cola with ice it's 95 degrees out
they go go there and see some Jagged
tooth wealth
Welcome to My Ride aliens are not
interested in you do you know where
aliens did go Brazil they created the
Brazilian Butler oh my God
now that being said that UFO trials
complete
laughs